hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva and
I'm the Cuyler Minh the collar man from
Instagram and Twitter is here with me
today we're gonna watch a movie trailer
better watch out
today's page from today shout out is
going to be for James stage ends it's
Christmas hey set from the visit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll find you don't worry we'll protect
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
that is that's a bold movie right there
to get a bunch of children to start I
was like oh it's gonna be harm to the
kids in the house no no no it's kind of
a cross between home alone and have you
seen funny games yeah that's what it
reminds yeah it's like home alone meets
funny games it's like kids instead
though I love her that kid is too like
creepy one who's like hurting all these
people I love that guy it's I mean it's
literally the realistic dealing with
teenage bullies and stuff like that
looks really entertaining so a lot of
familiar cast members in that there was
Jason from Power Rangers I saw and there
was was he there yeah yeah he was one of
the bullies that were like the og Power
Rangers no no no no the the read other
room a new one yeah dr. Zachary
Montgomery oh he is in here it is her
okay I recognize the one boy from the
visit and then apparently the the girl
is the sister from the visit to they're
both in here they got to do a third one
together now that's so cool they're
sorry again another horror movie another
like horror comedy together now that kid
the main the main creep I'm the main
I've seen the main Kevin McCallister
Levi Miller
oh he's pan he's the Peter he was Peter
and Pam at that movie that did that did
Tara know that was a fantastic film it's
a red band trailer but it's not like too
violent no no but I'm kind of hoping
that they commit hardcore to the
violence because when you're dealing
with like kids and at committing these
crimes themselves you know I saw it and
then like bad things happened to those
kids
and you see some violence it's a
different story when you see like the
kids committing the violence
I'm really hoping they can really
balance that tone between like kids
doing things which look even it funny
it's really hard to market like horror
or Christmas movies this lead kid he has
such a sweet face so it's like so
unsettling it was so perfectly creepy
and charming at the same time see him as
like a cherub or an angel or something
yeah it's just like hit the guy with the
baseball bat he's like seems like he's
gonna like really be pushed to the edge
by the end of this story when he's like
freaking out and everybody we just saw
the trailer for tragedy girls were just
watching stories kids I guess that's a
new mainstream thing I do the trailer
definitely took me for a surprise when
you're thinking like oh it's the kids
are gonna be haunted by the the ex who's
obsessive or whatever yeah and then it
took a total twist to it which gave a
real funny game's vibe which I
appreciate because this looks bizarro
and twisted if you're gonna do a
Christmas horror comedy that's the way
to do it make it twisted you know I
don't think it's ever been done like
this before no no cuz it's not
supernatural no you know I feel like
long ago we got Krampus yeah which was
supernatural this isn't supernatural at
first I thought this was just basically
a continuation of like that sorority
movie black Christmas black Christmas
yeah it reminds me a black Christmas at
least that's where I thought it was
gonna start and then it ended up being
something completely original the
direction looks good the humor looks
solid the actors look really fantastic
especially as Levi kid yeah you're right
it is like the more realistic
interpretation of home alone because I
remember being a kid and I have
sleepovers and like if I was with as
like super over a guy's house we had
always like freaked ourselves out to be
like what if someone breaks him we gotta
prepare just like set up stuff just in
case comes in now you're gonna take this
person down
that's the problem with the movie home
alone is they forgot that they might
actually accidentally turn children into
murderers really entertaining anyway
James stage ends I'm gonna give you your
page from the day shout-out I really
like this trailer because I'm pretty
sure James Sagan's went through this
exact experience after getting to know
James Sagan's he does just like how we
gave JT a shout out on the tragedy girls
video james Sagan's also kind of has a
little bit of that serial killer vibe he
has you know the glasses he smokes
cigarettes inside of his home he's kind
of quiet and laughs at weird things he
just seems like he would be this Levi
kid it was in here and I just wouldn't
be surprised if James Sagan's was was
like this is partially inspired by a
true event that he went through when he
was younger
I'm telling you you got it if you see
James taegons you're gonna be like oh
don't trust this guy yeah James taegons
terrifies and just listen to the name
James Sagan's
yeah that sounds like steak but I'll see
you on the Google hangout in a couple of
days James Takens hopefully you catch a
shout out just in time say you're as
comfortable to be yourself when we're
doing the Google hangout my friends
don't murder us dumb or get lives in
another state but he also seem that the
kind of guy who would buy a plane ticket
just to come to my home and kill me I
better watch out subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
that Kyler Minh is on Twitter and
Instagram go go check out his fan theory
YouTube channel feel the flame on the
south